Jim costa traveled to us from western
North Carolina and despite the impacts of
Hurricane Irma and many delays,
he made it in late last night.
So we're glad to have him here.
James t Costa is a professor of biology
at Western Carolina University and
Executive Director of the highlands
biological station and a trustee of the
Charles Darwin Trust. He lives in the
Blue Ridge mountains of North Carolina.
In his book, Darwin's backyard, how
small experiments led to a big theory.
He goes beyond the portrait of Charles
Darwin as a brilliant thinker to
concentrate on him as a
nimble experimenter delving
into some of evolutions.
Greatest mysteries. Please join
me in welcoming professor Costa.
Thank you all for being here. It's really
a special pleasure. Um, I have, you know,
a deep connection with Cambridge,
but I've never had the pleasure
of visiting your office is here,
so this has been great
seeing the place with you. So
thanks. Thanks so much. And a,
I do appreciate your being
here and, um, you know,
allowing me to share one of my passions.
You know, my background is entomology,
but some years ago it became pretty
interested in the history of evolutionary
thinking. And a lot of my work in
recent years has been on Darwin.
Alfred Russell Wallace has fellow
naturalist of the 19th century. And, um,
I became intrigued by, you
know, what we, what, what,
what lessons Darwin might still
hold for us today. You know,
kind of understanding how he came
to his yeah. His ideas. And, um,
some years ago I worked on an annotated
version of on the origin of species and,
and working on that project, I,
I came to realize that, you know,
a whole lot of the arguments
and the origin are,
are based on these often
really quirky experiments,
like literally backyard experiments.
And I became fascinated
by that side of Darwin,
especially because the Darwin that I saw,
you know,
as you get to know this individual,
the flesh and blood person a really
seemed at odds with the, you know,
Darwin, the icon Darwin
that, um, you know, the,
this is the kind of Darwin
that most people think of you,
do you think you think of these portraits.
And he said,
this is the melancholy Darwin, this is the
sad Darwin, maybe the tormented Darwin.
Um, the, you know, uh, I believe
that what we're seeing here,
this kind of cardboard cutout,
you know,
icon that seems rather rather melancholy,
um,
is really more,
you know,
w w w more insightful may be a Victorian
portraiture conventions or limitations
of the photographic technology of the day
where you're not going to hold a smile
for many long minutes. Um, really, I,
I came to appreciate this impish
side of Darwin. I saw this Darwin as,
um, as a dad, as a husband, as a friend,
as a jokester, a practical joker, you
know, so about sort of twinkle in his eye.
And I want to, you know,
um, share with you, um,
this idea of what Darwin did literally
in his backyard. Um, and how, you know,
the, the, how those activities kind
of give us a, uh, what I think is a,
is a much more, um, accurate portrait
of the human being. You know, Darwin,
the person,
and as you'll see,
my secondary interest in this project
wasn't just a humanized Darwin,
but also as an educator,
as a scientist myself. Um,
I became interested in the
ways in which Darwin, uh,
and his method could be harnessed
pedagogically. We can use that,
um,
at really any level from kindergarteners
up to college students and really use
the way he approached understanding
the natural world. Um, as a,
as an interesting novel way
to approach science education.
I'm teaching about ecology, evolution,
scientific inquiry, those sorts of things.
So,
so this is a portrait,
really have a rather different kinds of
Darwin than I think most of you would be
familiar with. In all likelihood.
This is one, a quote from Darwin. Um,
in his self deprecating way. He would
talk about his fullest experiments.
He loves fools experiments.
He's always making them and that kind of
gives them insight into what he's up to,
the backstory to Darwin's books
as experiment after experiment.
Some of them very quirky, um, on the fly,
literally done at home because famously
he became something of a home body and
did not travel much after his,
around the world voyage on HMS Beagle.
And I want to give you sort of have
some insight into Darwin again, uh,
as a family man. Uh, and
the way that his family,
his kids played a role in many
of these quirky experiments.
Some Darwin, um, had 10 children,
seven of whom survived to
adulthood and throughout their, um,
their upbringing,
they're constantly involved in dad's
activities and a as well as his wife,
Emma, as well as nieces and nephews.
Um, you know, the extended family.
And so, you know, there are
some interesting, um, you know,
little snippets of,
you know,
getting some sense of how the kids
were involved at different times.
So one anecdote for example that's
pretty well substantiated, you know, uh,
comes from one of the kids who, you know,
for about an eight year period, Darwin,
um, famously, you know, immersed himself
in the study of Barnacles of all things.
And so for at least one of the kids
their whole life as they were growing up,
they knew nothing.
My Dad working on barnacles and the story
goes that visiting some friends, um,
the, you know, they kind of looked,
looked around and wondering, well,
where does your dad do? Is
Barnacles, you know, um, like every,
every kid's dad must work on Barnacles,
you know, is the idea. And, um, you know,
some of their studies, some of their
investigations were just, you know, fun,
but always an interesting scientific point
behind them. So one episode involved,
I'm chasing around Bumblebees,
which we now understand male bees,
trap lining pheromonal the leading
trails kind of through an area.
They had no idea. Pheromones had not
been discovered yet at this time.
And they're running around and marketing
bs with flour to make them more visible.
And,
um,
it was just really quite a
family adventure to try to
understand what are these
bees doing?
It was the mystery of the buzzing places.
One of the kids later reminisced
that at that time, you know,
that his father was like a boy
amongst other boys. Um, and,
and I think that that says a lot.
This is,
and I think all of you can
perhaps appreciate this.
There's a certain childish enthusiasm,
a sense of wonder and enthusiasm about
something interesting in the natural
world.
And then trying to under understand it.
Here's just one other little example
of involving the kids. Um, this,
this is from a,
you can imagine maybe little
red periodical called the
entomologists to weekly
Intelligencer. You know, you can
imagine, you know, that every house,
all it must be reading this
magazine. So, you know,
here you've got a little note about
the f the capture of some rare beetles.
And this is obviously dad
writing the note, but signing it,
three of the kids, right? Frances
Lennard and Horace Darwin, ages 11,
nine and eight. And so that you can
sort of envision, that's the proud dad.
He loved Beatles himself on these quite
a beetle collector. And just very proud,
I think that his kids were,
you know, really into Beatles
too and collecting them.
And, um, so he fires off
this little note, you know,
to the weekly and entomologists weekly
intelligence are pretty interesting.
So those are little, little snippets, you
know, Darwin, uh, at his home, um, in,
in Kent Down House had a thinking path.
This is his thinking path.
And um, he would famously, you
know, put a few stones at one,
at one end of the thinking path and kick
them away as he made his rounds and the
kids would go and replace them.
Really wanting to keep them going longer
because there was always something
interesting to be found.
Um,
so I think that the thinking path
is a good place to start, you know,
in talking about Darwin's
experiments and they are fun.
A lot of his experiments are really
just genuinely fun, you know,
rather quirky,
rather odd always.
There's an interesting scientific
question behind them as well. We'll,
we'll discuss. Um, they are accessible,
you know, and this is interesting too.
I mean, Darwin working in the Victorian
period, literally at his home,
he's,
he's not working with sophisticated
scientific instrumentation maybe beyond a
microscope on really,
his experiments are done on the fly.
He's just pulling together,
you know, whatever materials
are at hand at the house,
and then devising a way to test some
scientific question that actually makes us
experiments eminently accessible today,
right?
We don't need sophisticated
scientific instruments, for example,
precision instruments in order to
actually engage in meaningful scientific
inquiry necessarily.
And there's interesting implications for
teaching scientific inquiry, I think. Um,
and of course adaptable.
I think that any of these experiments
and the questions behind them are adapted
to virtually any age group. They, some of
them are adaptable to kindergarten age.
Some of them,
you know,
there were layers of sophistication
where you can get into more sophisticated
considerations like replication
or concepts like, um,
statistical significance at the college
level perhaps or high school level. Um,
so scalable and adaptable,
which I think also makes them
eminently interesting. Um, from a,
from an educational point
of view today. Right. So,
so what was the experiment sizing,
you know, really all about? Well,
first and foremost about curiosity,
right?
It all starts with curiosity about the
natural world, natural phenomena, pattern,
process. Um, but ultimately
as I'll show you,
Darwin became very keen on really,
um,
not just demonstrating the voracity of
his ideas about evolutionary change and
the mechanism of natural selection,
but ultimately extending that paradigm.
And so many of his research programs
are really intended to flesh out,
um,
reconfirm and extend his
evolutionary insights as we'll see.
So editors is what he's looking for.
Um,
if any of you have read on the
origin of species, you may,
you may recall that near
the end of the book,
Darwin refers to the book as one long
argument and it hangs together in an
interesting way,
many different subjects.
And I became fascinated by the fact that,
you know,
there's another book behind the book
behind the one long argument and that book
is this one, right? His experiment
book is experiment notebook.
This is the book that he committed,
um, many, many observations,
experimental results, musings and so
on. And I'll give me just, you know,
there's so much that could be discussed.
I'm just going to give you
one example of an Eh, uh,
a research area that had,
that really shows off the different
facets of Darwin's, um, method and,
and his interests. So, so, and that, that
is that, that example will be dispersal,
take dispersal. That is the question
of geographical distribution.
How do species become distributed
on the earth as we see them?
And he undertook,
you know,
just a diversity of weird and wonderful
experiments to gather data to answer
questions that often we would just say,
well, of course, or that must be obvious,
but if there were no data, nobody really
knew. So he, you have to start somewhere.
So he,
so for example,
this is just a list of some of the
quirky experiments that he undertook,
you know, bomb seeds and
salt water seed, buoyancy,
hitchhiker experiments with duck's feet,
you know, Dunkin ducks and, and you know,
Aquaria with duckweed and,
and so on. So, so for example,
um, Galapagos Islands, right? Remote
Oceanic Islands loom large, uh, in,
in, in talking about Darwin and the
history of evolution. Um, so, but,
but it begs a question, any remote island
system begs the question, you know, what,
how new species get there. Exactly. It's
easy enough to see that might be blown,
you know, far off course or you
know, other winged animals. Um,
but really there's a lot of other
organisms besides things that can fly.
How do they get there? Well, you know,
maybe they raft or they float or
they can be carried in some way,
but how exactly. Darwin was convinced
that an whole lot of these organisms,
seeds and such actually floated
some of them just in salt water,
some of them rafting. Um,
but his, his colleagues,
his friends and colleagues who are
generally supportive of him, um,
really were dubious of this.
They didn't think that seeds could
possibly survive exposure to salt water,
you know, so what to do, but you
know, tests to demonstrate this.
And Darwin never did anything by halves.
So he embarked upon a two
year investigation, floating
seeds and salt water.
And not just an end of,
you know, two or three,
but really just taking over the house,
you know, just said, you know, you know,
jar after jar of saltwater with seeds
of, you know, Marian species, you know,
he fills up the cellar, you know,
he fills up his study. Um, the,
the object was to see, we'll, how long can
see survive exposure to salt water. Um,
so you would take samples periodically.
Can they survive a week?
Can they survive two weeks, a month,
two months, five months. And you know,
the kids were very excited because
his good friend Joseph Hooker,
the botanist was very dubious of this.
He didn't think that anything would
come of it. Um, so the kids got in on,
you know, they saw it as a contest
and in one letter to hooker,
he reported that the children were very
eager and asked Tim often whether he
would beat Dr Hooker and show him yet,
yes, they can survive in saltwater,
you know, yes, that can't happen.
Then there's the inconvenience of
hooker kind of pointing out that, well,
they might be able to survive in
saltwater, but oftentimes they sink.
And so it's a moot point whether
they can survive in saltwater,
they're never gonna make it to
an island if they're sinking.
And I'm in another letter, you know,
he writes to hooker, his, you know,
you see his exasperations, you know, the
gift, the con founded seeds will sink.
I've been taking all this
trouble, insulting the
ungrateful rascals for nothing,
right? The letters, you know,
his, his diary, the letters,
um,
his notebooks,
they really are this
phenomenal window into Darwin,
the person and the working method. And
so here you see, you know, um, you know,
you can try on and then set backs.
You know,
what does he do in the face
of sinking seeds? Well, you
know, let's try dry seeds.
Let's try flow. I'm drying
vegetation, let's try fruits.
And so these are just pages
from the experiment book
where species after species,
after species, he's testing them
and trying to see, you know,
how long will they float? A,
how long will seed survive.
Ultimately this all makes it into,
on the origin of species.
He is able to show that they could survive
some many of these species months at
a time. Ocean currents can carry them
thousands of miles. He's, you know,
triumphantly saying this is a viable means
for getting species to remote oceanic
islands. As unlikely as it may
be, it clearly must happen, right?
Um, in the book, you know,
each chapter ends with a kind of do it
yourself section where you can sort of
experiment ties all La
Darwin. You can, for example,
replicates some of his seed salting
experiments. And, um, do you know,
is it's great fun. I've done this with
science educators. I've done it with,
with my kids and other kids. Um, I've done
it with my students and, uh, you know,
again,
it's not just fun,
but actually there is this interesting
point about better understanding,
you know, geographical distribution,
dispersal of species on the planet,
and you think about it, lakes and
ponds are like islands on the land.
How do aquatic organisms get around
from lake to lake pond to pond? Well,
logically you might think, well
they're, maybe they're carry,
cause clearly little aquatic snails are
not leaving a pond to go miles and miles
to another pond. Right? Probably
they're carried. Well, once again,
it's our been thought of that,
but there were no data,
there was just no information one way or
another. So, so, so what does he do? Well,
well, he devises a test that
uses actual duck's feet, right?
Presumably they're eating these ducts,
he's saving the legs and then dangling
the legs in Aquaria full of snails to see
if the snails will hop aboard the feet.
He's imagining that sleeping ducks in
lakes, uh, as the feet are dangling down,
snails will become hitchhikers in the
morning. They're duck wakes up off.
It flies maybe hundreds of miles carrying
the snail with it, you know. So, um,
I devise, of course we, you know,
in my version we're not going to
use real duck feet. Um, but we have,
there's a way to make a model
duck foot out of a dowel in a,
in a bobber or some kind of a float
and you know, a fabric duck foot.
And actually this is one of my kids here.
We're actually sort of casting
for hitchhikers, you know, in,
in ponds and it's amazing actually what
you will catch kind of casting duck's
feet in ponds, all odd Darwin. So it's a,
it's really a great way to get young
people engaged with these scientific
questions. Now this is a general subject
that also says something about Darwin,
the crowdsource or I think he's maybe
the original crowd sourcer, you know,
these are just four letters to the editor,
open letters that he published in
1855 as one example, where again,
he's wondering about seeds surviving
and salt water. He's wondering,
has anyone ever looked at this? Are
there any data? Is there any information?
So publishing open letters,
will any of your readers a be so kind
as to inform me whether it's such
experiments? I've already been tried,
he's exhorting readers of this magazine,
the Gardener's chronicle, try this
experiment, send me your results. Um,
ultimately several people took him up on
this and they're cited in the origin of
species actually. So it's pretty,
pretty interesting. Um, so he's,
he's crowdsourcing here and he does this
to good effect with quite a few other
other subjects as well.
He's also open to the two rather
unorthodox approaches to the question.
And here's yet another facet.
Here's one of the kids, um,
little Francis or he as he was
called when he was eight years old,
came up with an experiment and
it seems a little crazy. So,
but here's Darwin reporting this to
his buddy Joseph Hooker. He says, look,
I must tell you another of my
profound experiments. You know,
he's sort of very tongue in cheek
about how profound it is. He says,
Frankie says to me,
why shouldn't a bird imagine a Burg
with seeds in its crop killed by hail or
lightening or something over the open
ocean and then the carcasses floating and
eventually is kind of washed up on a
distant shore and has fertilizer built in,
right with the rotting carcass. And
wouldn't that be a dispersal mechanism?
So where does Darwin say no sooner
said than done? He takes a poor pigeon,
right?
Um,
we've got seeds in the crop and this poor
pigeon is killed and is floating in a
salt water tank for 30 days.
And then Darwin is able to report once
the plants it, ah, the seeds, they,
they germinated splendidly
right data, right. Um,
very interesting.
Well,
a whole different area of interest
to him had to do with field botany.
And um, here's this was from
another letter. You know,
if you ever catch quite a beginner,
I want to give them a taste for botany.
Haven't make a perfect list
of some little field or wood.
And he speaks from experience here.
He really was passionate about botany
and he had listed the help of Catherine
Thorley, who is the governess
of the kids, call him,
had a talent for botany and very
keen on helping with experiments.
So they would botanize and try to
characterize the diversity in sent areas,
really a forerunner runner of the modern
quadrant approach to doing botanical
surveys. Um, here you see glimpses
in the letter of his sense of humor.
Um, like for example, when he identified
his first grass, which botanically can be,
they can be very difficult to identify
and he says, Hurrah, Hurrah. You know,
I never expected to make out of
grass in my life, you know. Well,
what's interesting about these experiments
with Miss Thorley is that they are
the forerunners of experiments that are
now considered to be foundational in
modern ecology and evolution.
So modern ecological concepts that you'll
find in any introductory bio textbook,
any introductory ecology course. And the
students learn about niche partitioning,
competitive exclusion, um,
they learned about, um,
on demographic analysis and
Population and population pressure.
Though those insights came
from these simple experiments.
And as you can see in the upper right
here, literally in Darwin's backyard,
this is down house and he's
has a three by four plot, uh,
where he is conducting experiments.
Um,
the so called lawn plot
where he mo's all around,
but he leaves the unknown plot just
to watch the dynamics of the different
species that come and go.
He sort of chronicling that
and he wants to document the,
he has a hypothesis about the relationship
of the different species that end up
coexisting.
The phyletic diversity packed into a
very small geographical area or the weed
garden where he clears the plot completely
and marks every seedling as it comes
up.
Essentially it is,
it is a modern demographic
study he's looking at, um,
at the mortality rate of these plants.
And he documents the on the extreme
what he calls of course the struggle for
existence, the mortality rate, um,
that ends up reinforcing his arguments
about how natural selection works.
So I find it fascinating that
those cornerstone ecological
principles today have
their origin in these simple backyard
experiments. And again, you know,
anybody can duplicate these experiments
that I think it's actually great fun, um,
to take Darwin's original data and then
compare that with with one's own data.
I'm doing these, these different law
and plots or, or we'd gardens. Well,
if the origin is one long argument,
consider that the origin was far
from Darwin's last book, right?
There's another dozen or so books,
uh, after on the origin of species.
About half a dozen of them
on botanical subjects.
Every one of these books
has interesting experiments.
Some of them pioneering where Darwin
made fundamental discoveries, um, in,
um, in different aspects of ecology,
evolution, botany, behavior. These are,
this is just a sampler of, of topics, you
know, orchids, Barnacles, inheritance,
you know, the construction of B
cells, expression of emotions,
pollination mechanisms.
He's often juggling multiple
experimental areas at the same time,
which is interesting in its own right.
Planting experimental gardens in his yard.
Eventually building a greenhouse.
This is Darwin's greenhouse where he
would keep climbing plants, orchids,
carnivorous plants.
And so on.
His first book after the
origin was on orchids in fact,
and he was fascinated by
the different contrivances,
the highly derived adaptations of orchids
and their pollination relationship
with insects,
often one,
one to one relationship and fascinated
by the different ways that orchids
package their pollen and then deliver
the pollen through adhering them to
insects. And he discovered that some,
like the one in color here, cat Hasidim,
some of them don't simply stick their
pollen to an insect that can forcibly fire
their pollen at, at insects. Um, one
of his, his neighbor and protege,
John Lubbock, um, in a,
in a memoir that he published in 1874
commented on how Mr Darwin has been so
good as to irritate one of
these flowers in my presence.
The plenty IOM was thrown nearly three
feet when it struck and adhere to the
pain of a window,
Darwin and his impish way.
It would sometimes take
on friends and family,
sort of who are unaware of showing
them around his greenhouse.
And then he would
surreptitiously trigger a cat,
a see them and get it to fire pollen
at the, at, at his visitors. Um,
there are several accounts of that.
He would also go out to a, uh,
a favorite family picnic
spot near the house.
He called it the family called
it Orkis Bank. Uh, for it's,
it's nice to native orchids and, uh,
at sites like this, he would study,
uh, how insects, um, transfer pollen
like this beautiful Burnett and off,
you'll notice that the fun, it's coiled
proboscis. How's those yellow, uh,
structures? Those are the millennia. Those
are the pollen packets of the orchid.
Um, and then the, uh, the drawing
here is from Darwin's orchid book.
He's looking at these malls,
unfurling that proboscis and really
interested in demonstrating exactly how
insects, um, lock and key, the sort
of relationships are our fitting,
uh, with, with their orchids. Right.
And that's just one little bit
of his adventures in pollination.
Um,
Darwin spent inordinate amounts of time
studying the ways insects interacted
with flowers.
The,
there were accounts of the family
visiting the Zoological Gardens in London
while the kids and everyone
else are looking at the animals.
Darwin is crawling in the flower beds
and he's making observations like you see
up here, upper right, this is taken from
the experiment book. He's, he's drawing,
um, the, you know, the ways in which
bees will approach certain flowers.
He's interested in also
trip action mechanisms.
Like you find that Inbar
berries or Mahonia where
they're very touch sensitive,
uh, an insect just approaches and touches
the flower slightly. And then the,
you know, the, the statements will,
will suddenly be triggered and they will
shower the insect with pollen, um, or,
or beans, the common bean, which has,
it's a statement and pistols wrapped up.
He calls it like a French horn.
When these land on those
down hanging pedals outed,
comes in and dabs pollen
on the back of the B.
So he documented meticulously
numerable cases of,
of pollination. And he made
an interesting discovery. Um,
it wasn't completely new.
Botanists knew about this but
didn't know what it meant.
And this is the phenomenon known
as Hetero styley and it's a,
it's a case of two or more flower morphs.
Uh,
he first discovered it in primroses, uh,
so-called female morph and a male morph.
So the one on the, on
the, on the left here,
the female morph has a very long
pistol and very short statements.
The male morph has the reverse.
It has very long stamens as you see here.
And a very, very short pistol. Well,
he was fascinated by this and Darwin and
his characteristic way thinks big and
he's interested in the evolution
of sexes, right? Big Picture.
And he thinks maybe this is an example
of evolution in action that may be the
female morph is eventually becoming
a female only flower evolutionarily.
And the male morphous
becoming a male only flower,
which you do find in some groups.
So maybe this is an example of
evolution in action. So he has this,
this hypothesis and what do you do? You
know, the first thing to do is, you know,
document, document the frequency.
He Marshall's the troops,
the troops are the kids. So he gets
the kids, you know Horace, who's nine,
Lenny Frankie Bessie out they
go. And this is, these are,
this is a page from the experiment
book collecting primroses and he says,
my May 13th,
my children gathered great bunch of cows,
lips 79 stocks where male flowers,
52 were female flowers.
And then he would do cross after
cross after cross after cross.
These are all from the experiment
book documenting how he would, um,
hand transfer pollen.
And ultimately when,
when the seeds form
then count up the seeds.
And his hypothesis hypothesis
is that the female morph,
um,
that would perhaps have more seeds,
significantly more seeds produced
than the male morph. Well,
interesting hypothesis,
but he butted right up against his friend.
Huxley is Great Tragedy Of Science,
right?
The slaying of a beautiful
hypothesis by an ugly fact.
And the ugly fact in this case was that
he found exactly the opposite of what
his working hypothesis suggested.
Right.
And indeed that was the male morph that
ended up producing more seeds than the
female morph. Um, so, you know,
nonetheless informative in its own way.
Ultimately he got it right.
He had published a whole separate
book on this subject we're in,
which he argued that
these different morphs,
their function evolutionarily is to
enforce out crossing cross fertilization.
And it's now been documented in a great
multitude of, of plant groups, um, in,
in my book, um, in that, in that spirit
of, of Darwin's experimental rising,
of course,
I have examples of some of the plans
that he explored and instructions on how,
you know, they're different pollination
mechanisms can be explored by, um,
you know, experimental
enthusiasts, schoolkids et Cetera.
A couple more examples for you.
Carnivorous plants. So again,
thinking big picture,
Darwin's interested in plant like
animals and animal like plants.
And of course there were two groups
of plants that are, you know,
just eminently animal like,
and one is the carnivorous plants and
he's smitten first by Sun dews and his
wife Emma comments, uh, in a
letter to a two to a friend.
He hopes in the end to prove it to be
an animal and she's only half kidding.
He really does think that, you
know, in such groups who can,
you can see that plant animal,
um,
intersection that they
have common ancestry,
that there are physiological and other
mechanisms that they have in common.
So what does he do?
The very first thing he does is begin to
explore their dietary preferences. Um,
so he's on holiday in Bournemouth
and first he tries his hair,
then he tries his toenails, you know, um,
and of course not very profound results.
Right. You know, clearly
though they don't,
they sort of spit out the hair and
they spit out the toenails. Um, but,
but he embarks upon a year's
long investigation of the
dietary preferences of
Sun dews and fly traps and eventually
really does get it right. He understands.
He can see the fore runner of digestive
enzymes that were later to be discovered
in animals on pepsin and and such.
Um,
and so I give some examples of how
you can replicate some of Darwin's
experiments trying,
um,
different delights that they really
enjoy and some that they don't like very
much and exactly the way Darwin
founded fly traps as well.
Darwin found that, um,
these little tricombs,
there's a certain frequency and sequence
for touching these little tricombs on
the inner surface of a fly trap
necessary to trip the, the trap. And um,
you know,
that's all easily replicated using
a probe or a hair climbing plants.
That's the other group that seems a group
of plants that seems eminently animal
like,
and Darwin made an independent discovery
of the principle of circum nutation,
the constant circular probing
movement of climbing plants.
It turns out that almost all plants,
they're growing shoots move in that way,
but it's highly elaborated and
adaptive and climbing plants.
And tendrils and growing
shoots. So what did he do? Well,
he commandeered the family
terrarium, right? So, so every,
every fine home had a miss mailings,
patent, indoor pancakes of course.
Um,
and in their parlor they had one of these,
but Darwin Room removed all the
ornamental plants, took it over,
put climbing plants in there.
And you see in the lower left here how
he used the pop of the glass with tracing
paper with a climbing plant inside a
little markers and reference points so he
can follow the movement of the
very end of the growing tip.
And in that way documented
that circular movement.
And he coined the term circle mutation,
which is still used today. Very,
very interesting. And of course
hops as a great example of a,
of a plant that circle new tastes in a,
in a wonderful way,
fairly frequent movement in
that, uh, or fast movement.
And so I give instructions on how one
can create a circle of new tolmatter.
I'm either using a clock,
like disc or,
or compass coordinates and sort of
document. The way the shoot is, is moving.
We'll finally, um, Darwin really
back way back in the 1830s,
was fascinated by earthworms.
And this is also the subject
of his very last book.
So this kind of bookends
Darwin's experimental life.
He's fascinated by earthworms
as a geological force.
And then also later on he became really
interested in earthworms intelligence
and their personality traits and their
preferences, which seems a little,
a little funny, but he's very serious
about that. Uh, in one letter to a niece,
he sorta confides how he's becoming
deeply attached to worms is fascinated by
them all through the 1870s. He's
working on them as a geological force.
He believes that earthworms slowly,
surely inexorably rework the landscape,
right? They're undermining, they're taking
soil up in the form of their castings,
they're turning over soil and
that way objects slowly sink.
And he even collected data
from sites like Stonehenge.
You went out to stone henge great fallen
blocks of stone and was measuring how
deeply it had sunk.
He was looking at Roman ruins,
how deeply different artifacts have sunk,
and then experimentally trying this by
putting blocks of stone out in fields and
then monitoring years. How's
they slowly subside. In fact,
his son, Horace, who later founded the
Cambridge Scientific Instrument Company,
I'm really showed his
experimental bent pretty early.
So this is his youngest son and Horace
designed what is known as the worms stone.
And this is still in evidence
that down house today,
the warm stone is a millstone and Horace
designed a precision micrometer and you
see it here, he actually
published this, the,
the plans for this in nature in 1,901.
Um,
and the idea was that with
a precision micrometer,
the subsidence of the of the millstone
can be very carefully measured, right?
So the action of the worms could
be quantified in that way. Um,
so in that way he quantified
the rate of subsidence,
but the other half of that equation
is the soil brought to the surface.
So with his niece, Lucy, Lucy Wedgewood,
he devised quadrats where they would
collect warm castings and then ultimately
quantify how much soil and the form of
worm castings is deposited per unit area.
And then extrapolate over
time. This makes it, of course,
until that very last book on Earth Worms,
they were able to show that up
to 16 tons of soil per acre,
or moved annually by the earthworms,
which is truly, truly remarkable. Right?
Um, one other interest though, right?
So worms as a geological force, but,
but also again, there their
intelligence, their predilections.
If you visit Down House today,
this is the parlor as you can visit
it and you might notice something. Um,
over here on the back on the piano,
you'll notice a flower pot.
And one might assume
that in fact there are,
there should be flowers in the flower pot.
But no,
the flower pots were
Darwin's where Murray's,
this is where he would
keep his earthworms. And
this recreates one episode,
uh, in the, in the late
1870s where Darwin,
his son Francis and his grandson
Bernard and his wife Emma,
played musical instruments to the
earthworms. Um, so we have Emma on piano.
She's quite an accomplished pianist.
I'm Francis on bassoon and the
little grandson on penny whistle.
And the idea is to sort of see,
you know, what, what is, you know,
do they have any musical appreciation?
Can they hear even, you know? Well, um,
well Emma, again, in her
tongue in cheek style,
she writes a letter to
Leonard who is away. He says,
father has taken a training.
Earthworms, it doesn't make much progress.
They can neither see nor hear, you know.
Um, but nonetheless he was convinced that
they do have the ability to sense the
vibration and by moving the
flower pot off versus on the, the,
the piano. Um, and ultimately
to he devise experiments,
giving them paper cutout so different
shape and size and we document how they
feel these shapes and
how they make selections.
They like to align their burrows with,
um, with these things. And so you can see,
for example, in this reconstruction
that quite a few of these,
a bits of cabbage and paper
cutouts have disappeared.
And you can kind of test their,
their preferences for different shapes
and sizes of these paper cutoffs. Exactly.
The Way Darwin did well on
that is really just, you know,
the, the mirror asked introduction to
though the weird and wonderful world of
Darwin's experiment type
thing. Um, again, I,
I really do appreciate this opportunity
to, to share this with you. Um,
thanks so much for your attention to that.
And of course,
thank you.
And of course very happy to answer
any questions that you might have.
Yes,
thank you so much for the talk.
It was quite interesting.
I didn't know any thing about Darwin,
the man versus his science.
Um,
one thing I'm wondering is obviously
Darwin was special in his time because he
made a lot of discoveries and theories
that turned out to be true that others
did not make. So why was
he special? I mean, what,
what was it in his upbringing or in this
person or something that made him do
those things?
Do you know?
That's a good question. I mean,
of course he blundered a lot too.
There were a lot of, um, false
starts and dead ends as well. Um,
he Darwin himself
reflected on, on his, um,
insights on his successes and,
and he really thought that a,
that a certain persistence,
uh, was a lot of it. So He,
if he special, it may be that, um,
he really had a sticktuitiveness he
would have an idea and really pursue that
idea. I mean, just to the nth degree.
He would, he would pursue ideas.
Sometimes they just did not pan out.
You know, he just blew it completely.
But other times they ended up
yielding incredible insights.
And from a modern perspective,
it's really interesting,
especially for historians of science how
many fundamental scientific principles
and ecology and evolution have their
basis in these very simple backyard
experiments. But I think that a lot
of it is really the persistence.
Of course he had the advantage to,
this is with hindsight, right? But,
um,
he's one of the very few,
maybe apart from only from the
great Alfred Russell Wallace,
his colleague who independently discovered
the principle of natural selection.
He had this evolutionary view of things,
relationships in organisms,
uh, hit the history,
evolutionary history of organisms
down the mechanism behind it,
natural selection with that knowledge,
the benefit of that knowledge,
that guided many questions. Now the fact
that he got so much right, right when he,
he, he almost alone except
for Wallace had this vision.
And so he's really the only
one asking such questions.
So that also accounts for a lot of his
success of you're about the only one
investigating an area.
You're bound to be making a lot of the
first discoveries in, in that area.
Um, you mentioned a couple of his
partners that he worked closely with in
corresponded with and of course
he had partner with his kids,
it sounds like on some of these
experiments, but was there,
was there a larger network of
scientists that he was a part of,
sort of beyond call for,
you
know, crowd sourcing, um,
on a regular basis who
are sort of interested in
engaged in the same pursuits?
Yeah, that's a, that's a good
question. And I'm so, yeah,
despite the fact that Darwin became
quite a homebody, you know, he,
he rarely traveled except maybe
to some holiday destinations.
Maybe he went as far as Scotland
after his famous beagle voyage,
but really very much stayed
at home. And yet, you know,
quite a few scientific
visitors came to him.
And his correspondence is about
humanists, right? I mean, um,
tens of thousands of letters.
So he is very much a part of a scientific
network that is global. And of course,
once he achieves a certain level of fame,
people are very happy to send in data,
share information, and send specimens.
In addition right there in London,
London scientific society. He benefits
from his buddies. You know, Joseph Hooker,
uh, the botanist, you know,
one of the leading botanists
have his day in the UK. Uh,
certainly, um, is the
director of Kew Gardens.
And Q is perhaps at that time, you
know, the greatest center of, you know,
global center of living plants
and from around the world.
So Darwin is able to do
a lot of experimenting on
plants that hooker would very
kindly just Lendon,
you know,
so here you have the greatest national
collection at your fingertips, you know,
fabulous. And for quite a
few other, um, you know,
London was very much the center of,
of British scientific society.
And um,
he was never very far away.
He would sometimes go into the scientific
societies to meetings, reading papers,
but just as often they would
come to him. And so, um,
I think it's fair to say that
he was very much globally, uh,
certainly nationally and also globally
connected even though he rarely left home
all over. This is all a part of
course from the crowd sourcing.
Yeah, I was, I was thinking of a question
before you've sort of got into that,
about that idea of,
um,
geographically w what do you think were
the advantages besides this proximity to
London, of Darwin doing his
studies where he did them?
Do you think that there's
something about the ecology of, uh,
the sort of British isles that gave
him an advantage? Or do you think it,
it really was more just,
um,
being able to tap into that
global network that sort of,
the British empire had at the time?
That's a good question too. I
would say no, there's nothing.
I don't think that there's anything
really special about the place. In fact,
in some ways it's actually not a very
good place to conduct certain types of,
of experiments.
Um,
there are certain groups of organisms
that are very low in diversity,
for example. Um, I think
it more has to do with,
first of all these types of experiments,
they really can be conducted almost
anywhere, right? So there is that,
but beyond that, nothing in my opinion,
very special about that geography,
you know, immediately there. So
therefore benefiting more from,
um, from his, uh, his
place in society, you know,
proximity to London. Um, his,
his good friends who were really
leaders of British science at that time.
And then his ability through his own fame
and accomplishments, um, to, to attract,
uh, the, the, the support
of people around the world.
He had good friends here in the u
s um, he had, um, a global network.
I think that was more important than the,
than the particular geography.
The geography turns out to
be a tremendously interesting
and important, but, uh,
but I don't think that it
itself set the stage for the,
some interesting experiments necessarily.
Maybe with one exception.
And that would be earthworms
in any glacial landscape
dry. So not so here. Right.
In northern North America
glaciated landscape, um,
earthworms were extra Paden.
Right, so you're knocking, you don't have
nearly the same, you know, there were,
there are exotic worms introduced here,
but the native fauna was expert paid
it in the last glacial maximum. Um,
so that did not happen, you know,
um, where Darwin lived and so,
so maybe at least the earthworms
dependent on that geography. Yeah.
Yeah. Thanks for speaking. Um,
my question for you is why is Darwin
such a popular figure in even modern era?
Like there's a lot of sciences that did
a lot of amazing work such as Mendel
Hooker and we don't really know
their name off the top of our heads,
whereas Darwin,
even though he seems like he's very much
of a homebody and he's not like a fun,
quirky kind of guy, um, everybody
knows who he is even today.
So what is it about either the volume of
the work he created or the type of work
created that made him so well known?
Far and wide?
Yeah. Now that's a, that's a very
good question as well. I mean, I,
I think that it has much to do with um,
the very subject itself.
You know, Darwin becoming
associated, you know,
just inevitably with this idea of
evolution by natural selection.
And no, as I showed here after
the origin book after book,
I mean he really is reinforcing
and extending. So I mean he,
he truly saw the implications for this
idea and he sought it out in all of these
areas. So, you know,
he used to be maybe commended for really
solidifying and extending a body of
knowledge or a certain way
of understanding the world.
Um, but at the same time,
I think you all recognize that, um, in
some parts of the world, you know, uh,
including in our country,
right? The, the idea, um,
is polarizing and Darwin also became the
kind of therefore poster child for an
as sort of a, it's a, it's a caricature
really. But this idea that, um, that,
that the scientific ideas must
therefore be opposed to, um, to,
to religion and society.
Um,
some of some elements of that we're seeing
in British society and the late 19th
century.
Um,
and it'd be really became rekindled
and intensified and the 20th,
especially in the US,
I think that he represents that
idea that some people find, um,
deeply distressing, disturbing,
blasphemous, whatever,
however you want to put it.
As far as the, as the sort of poster
child almost for this idea, uh,
he then becomes iconic. And, um, and I,
I think that that's a
lot of it as well then.
And as is as true in the history
of science generally. Um,
it's unfortunate but true that there
are just a select few individuals I,
for whatever quirky reason,
end up becoming household
names and representing whole,
vast disciplines that actually have
armies of very talented investigators beat
behind them. Um, and those investigators
are unsung typically outside the field,
perhaps, and a and unknown. And
certainly with Darwin, it's,
it's all on a whole different scale
because of the societal implications of,
of these ideas,
I believe.
Thank you.
Everybody.